[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
off to jail
for steve bannon
poor guy
oh
it's amazing
they don't they they didn't understand
that the the pardon
how pardons work a federal pardon does
not prevent you from being charged in uh
state of like i don't know new york
so steve bannon
arrives arrives at the courthouse
to surrender to prosecutors i think he's
charged with five crimes is that right i
think it's five charges let's let's go
look at here i don't wanna i don't wanna
tell you wrong information here
especially about steve bannon looks like
two counts of money laundering three
counts of conspiracy
and one count of scheming too deep fraud
i mean isn't that just like
i mean really that's like the trump
administration and anyone to do a trump
in general two counts of money
laundering three counts of conspiracy
and one count of scheming to fraud
to defraud
oh
god damn steve bannon you piece of [ __ ]
i'm glad to see though that the uh
that the decaying blob of spam
will uh maybe maybe get a decent spam
sandwich
in the jailhouse i don't know do they
let spam eat
spam in the
in jailhouse i you know you've seen this
picture right a picture of the decaying
moldy piece of spam
it looks like bannon
that's
scabby steve
scabby steve now
this is uh
on top of
the contempt
and indictment charges and conviction
this is on top of that
this is not um
part of that this is an addition to that
so now steve bannon's not only charged
indicted and convicted in a federal
court now he's surrendering to
prosecutors
in a state court now
to be perfectly honest
if they give him jail time
for the federal charge of contempt of
congress he'll serve that sentence
whatever it is if they give him a prison
sentence he'll go serve that federal
time
while he's awaiting trial for these
state charges because he's not going to
go to trial on these state charges right
away now i i haven't heard if they're
going to an hour ago is when now we got
news of the charges but uh we haven't
heard if they're going to detain him
which they should [ __ ] detain him
[ __ ] that guy he's got federal charges
he's got state charges now the guy is
grifting all over his [ __ ] his trader
news network thing that he does
every single day
where he's defrauding and scheming to
defraud
his viewers and americans
so and i'm i'm sure i'm sure steve
bannon being good at money laundering
that he is learning from the best donald
trump that he's still doing that as well
these people are not stopping criming
they're not stopping this that's why
that's why the cheeto dust mobster's so
pissed off this morning at the lincoln
project did you see this the lincoln
the lincoln
the lincoln project puts a [ __ ] ad on
fox news
uh you call it fox news they put an ad
on on faux news
and he's [ __ ] pissed he's [ __ ]
pissed because lincoln project pointed
out the [ __ ]
fraud frauding scheme
that trump laid on his supporters in
2020 and they all [ __ ] fell for it
the save america pact and [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] legal defense fund and saved me
from my enemy fund whatever the [ __ ] it
is that he's doing whatever whatever
money laundering scheme that he's
committing on his supporters and these
brainwashed sheep keep sending in their
their [ __ ] social security checks and
their house payments to this fat slob
why i don't know
even mitch mcconnell yesterday that
[ __ ] coward wouldn't even comment on
donald trump's investigation
and how he stole
our top secret documents that apparently
include
the new clear secrets of a foreign
government
oh jesus [ __ ] christ
mitch mcconnell wouldn't even he's like
nope uh um i'm not gonna talk about that
because uh he's going to jail i mean i
mean they're they're terrified as
geraldo geraldo this morning geraldo
scary her owl though this morning
geraldo rivera
is like no [ __ ] trump [ __ ] him he's done
he's going to jail steven's going to
jail donald trump's going to jail cash
patel's probably going to jail we're
probably gonna mark meadows peter
navarro
john eastman jeffrey clark christina bob
i mean the list goes on and on and on
here folks on and on and on and on and
that is one reason why
one reason why
trump looks so damn stupid is because he
has no one around him anymore
they've all really abandoned him i mean
don't go out on tv and act like they
love him they'll do that because he
loves that oh [ __ ] he loves when they
get on tv and act like they [ __ ] love
him oh he [ __ ]
that's his thing
but i mean how hard is it to go on tv a
lie i mean these people are easy easily
go on tv and lie
i mean stephen miller
kellyanne conway and the like of course
he'll go on [ __ ] tv and live for this
son of a [ __ ] jesus christ even bill
barr won't won't do it anymore
because see bill maher knows he's going
to jail but bill barr doesn't give a
[ __ ] what does bill bark hear
bill bart's part of the
old darth vader republican party the
cheney types right
billboard doesn't give a [ __ ]
hell bill bart got his he got his book
he's not going to be he's not going to
be held accountable for how he buried
the mueller report he's not going to be
held accountable for that he knows that
what the [ __ ] he care what the hell
does he care he's moved on he didn't
commit any crimes when it comes to a
coup he got out but when the getting was
good baby
that's why bill bard's doing what he's
doing
it's like [ __ ] this guy
but we see steve bannon being toted into
the courthouse i'm gonna show the video
i'm gonna show the video of this lady
just absolutely incinerating steve
bannon as
he's walking into the courthouse
and this this i don't know who this is
bless her heart whoever this lady is in
new york city absolutely yelling and
screaming at steve bannon holding a sign
and destroying him as he walks into the
white house and he tries to play victim
of course of course he does he plays
victim as he walks into the courthouse
talking about how
the the mayor of new york city has sent
a a group of people down to the border
and to texas to tell greg abbott hey
stop human trafficking people to our
state you [ __ ] human trafficker stop
doing it if you're gonna do it let's
organize with it stop trafficking humans
you piece of [ __ ] greg abbott
so they sent people down there and he's
complaining oh i'm a victim my name's
steve bannon i'm a trump supporter and
i'm a victim
like yeah no [ __ ] sherlock we know we
know you think
you're a [ __ ] victim and you're
persecuted
oh but nothing's better
than the smell of six
six counts
in new york state this morning on scabby
steve bannon we also have news that the
uh the queen of england queen elizabeth
ii
is sick apparently she's recovering from
something there's not a lot of news
it seems like they're warning the world
that
you know i mean she is 96 she's been the
queen for like a thousand years uh you
know one thing i do want to say about
this
is that queen elizabeth really has the
perspective of that not a lot of folks
have this perspective and what i mean by
this is she was the queen
she was the queen
during a time where she watched
nazi not germany turn into nazi germany
she was there she was there now there
were a lot of people there but they
weren't the queen for crying out loud of
a country who was being bombed
bombed by nazi
germany and now she sees the world turn
to this far right fascism we have these
far-right fascists crawling out
underneath their rocks
here in america they're the america
first let's go brandon nazis
but there there's factions all around
the world and this is this really is an
infection and a disease
that is spreading rapidly um the
internet is a hell of a tool
it's a hell of a way to communicate all
around the world in an instant and a
second
and this is the reason why
we are having some of this trouble is
because we're still trying to figure
this out we're in the
infancy of
of communication over the internet and
what the effects are on society
and we we've watched
as
in this country close up some people
closer than others i mean i i'm here in
missouri where
it's kind of trump country
and i have relatives that have fallen to
this this maga delusion
that somehow the world's out to get them
and
most people refer to it as
maca but there's also this q anon
faction
and this brainwashing where steve bannon
can go and
talk about i think it's called we build
the wall i believe that is what the
[ __ ] the fund is called is we build a
wall
and this [ __ ] can just
say out in the universe hey give me your
money we'll go build a wall and we'll
stop the brown people from coming in our
country right
like that's that's the thing that steve
bannon tries to do and bam they
with the delusion and the right-wing
media just pumping this garbage into
their brains every day they they do not
hesitate to give steve bannon their
their house payment their social
security check
and steve bannon he's like yeah million
bucks hell yeah i'll put that right in
my pocket [ __ ] them because what they
don't know is steve bannon doesn't give
a [ __ ] about that wall he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about that wall he doesn't give a
[ __ ] if
if brown people come in the country he
doesn't care if people cross the border
he in fact wants people to cross the
border
he wants them to cross the border so he
has a demon to sell to
to his masses
so that he can collect and grift more
money this is why they're really [ __ ]
in a pickle here with ro
they're really in a [ __ ] pickle with
row
it's it's you know they say it's like
the dog who caught the car but really
it's the dog who tried to catch the car
and the [ __ ] car ran right over him
because that's that's that's what is
happening here
is that the republican party is finally
starting to figure out oh [ __ ] well i
mean if if we get real overturned
the only way for us to campaign is to go
even further right
to convince these these delusional
people that we're gonna ban abortion
everywhere you saw it with with laura
windsor last week with one of these
candidates he he
he stepped all over himself but he
absolutely said yes we will have a
federal ban
because that's what they want to do they
want to take away your [ __ ] rights
that's what these right-wingers want to
do and they use all kinds of excuses
they use all kinds of great stories
to do that
one of them is we build a wall yeah but
trump's we'll just elect trump he'll
build a wall he's elected well i can't
build a wall so go give steve bannon
your [ __ ] money and we'll pocket your
money that way the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
it's just nonsense absolute nonsense but
the greatest part about it all the
greatest part about it all is they're
being exposed right out in the open and
this morning no better time than this
morning where steve bannon's walking
into the courthouse acting like he's the
[ __ ] victim when he [ __ ] stole a
million dollars worth of his supporters
money that [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you
have donald trump donald trump this
morning whining and crying
on his fraud social about a [ __ ] ad
that lincoln project aired on fox
news if you want to call it news it's
not
if you want to call it that
this morning he's
he's posting on on fraud social that
i'm going to sue the link of course he's
gonna sue the lincoln project is what he
says get the [ __ ] out of here okay sue
them for what for telling the truth to
your [ __ ] supporters on a tv on a
trade or tv network that they're gonna
view and they're gonna see this ad yeah
okay try it i'd love to see the
discovery of that one
i'd love to see the discovery in that
case
and of course lincoln project is
probably going to dare him to sue him
but he's really mad he's really mad this
morning the steve bannon is charged with
this uh we build a wall fraud because it
was always a fraud from the very
beginning when he came down a [ __ ]
golden escalator and started demonizing
people of color
that that was it that was the [ __ ]
fraud from the very beginning
and then they started chanting bill wall
and it went on and on and on and on and
here we are steve bannon
donald trump's right hand man his
[ __ ] campaign ceo or whatever the
[ __ ] his title was whatever the [ __ ] his
title was when in 2016 when they were
colluding with russia to try to take
over our [ __ ] government
but here we have
donald trump and steve bannon really
pissed off this morning playing victim
which is not surprising
because
their frauds are coming to light
the other fraud that's coming to light
is is the right-wing media attacking
hillary clinton for for for calling
people deplorable and it's oh this is
this was setting up joe biden to call
people fascist as if as if that was the
goal you are fascist you are [ __ ]
nazis what are you what do you want from
us what do you want us to do you want us
to be nice to you no we are intolerant
of intolerance that is what we're going
to do the left has had enough of this
[ __ ] we've had enough of your crybaby
little fascist snowflake [ __ ] and we're
not putting up with it anymore we are
not going to be tolerant of intolerance
it's enough you can sit down and shut
the [ __ ] up
but hillary clinton makes a debut on the
view about this issue and fox news and
the rest of the right-wing media losing
their minds
that all they're demonizing people yeah
we are we're that's exactly what we're
doing we're demonizing people who are
are intolerant
of other human beings that is exactly
and we are going to politicize it that's
exactly what we're gonna do
because that's really what they want
they keep calling like there's gonna be
violence over this [ __ ] document
thing where the the former guy the
cheeto dust mobster
stole our [ __ ] documents our
government documents he stole top secret
foreign government nuclear secrets get
the [ __ ] out of here and and we're not
gonna if we indict him you guys are
gonna commit violence yeah okay that's
not what they're gonna do they're not
the threat of violence is not the huge
threat the threat here is that they take
over our governments
that is the [ __ ] real threat and
that's what you have to realize that's
what you have to do and engage in your
democracy and it's not just about
marking your ballot because you have the
power of the ballot you do have that
power but you can register folks to vote
still in some states you need to check
your registration to make sure it is
still good so you do have the power of
your ballot because let me tell you if
you live in a state that where a
republican has control over anything boy
they're really trying to take your
[ __ ] vote away from you you goddamn
right because they know you're going to
vote against fascism and that is not
something they want they definitely want
you to not vote if you hate fascists
hate them
like in florida or georgia
pennsylvania ohio they know it's coming
this morning they're talking about on
right-wing media these trader tv news
networks they're going to talk about
kevin mccarthy's going to release a
great plan really that's what you're
banking on
is kevin mccarthy releasing a plan
apparently kevin mccarthy is going to be
the new newt gingrich did you know newt
gingrich is still alive holy [ __ ] how
old is this guy i thought he was he's
got to be older than queen elizabeth
jesus christ this [ __ ] guy newt
gingrich but apparently kevin mccarthy
is going to be the new newt gingrich
she's going to release a great plan
that's going to deliver the house for
republicans
and it's all a distraction it's all a
distraction that's what that is
you do not need to play this game when
you're out there engaging in your
democracy you do not need to play the
game of trying to go on defense of what
kevin mccarthy's plan is guess what if
we tell them to [ __ ] off his plan
doesn't mean hell iota [ __ ] that plan
you can say [ __ ] that plan when you go
vote
that's what you can do
that's how you can do this you don't
have to play the game of talking to
someone about it even
hell i'm gonna crush it here on our show
when he releases this thing
every single thing i'm gonna [ __ ]
just destroy
because you know it's gonna be
destroyable they're republicans they're
fascists they're moglodites of course
it's gonna be easy to destroy their
little new
plan newt gingrich 2.0
that was [ __ ] 30 years ago
30 years ago
30 years ago newt gingrich
had this great plan they took back the
house that's their plan here
rick scott was supposed to be in charge
of that for the senate he [ __ ] that up
oh baby oh baby did rick's got [ __ ]
that up he's like yeah we want to take
away your medicare and take away your
social security and on top of that we
don't want women to have rights
oh great one great job
great job with the messaging there rick
thank you so politicize it
now they're going to have kevin mccarthy
of all people
unveil a great plan that we're going to
be able to destroy and again this is
only gonna give people more reason to go
vote against these [ __ ]
you know you know this [ __ ] is not gonna
talk about democracy
you know this [ __ ] is not gonna talk
about making sure school children start
at
an age of three instead of five you know
this is not going to talk about average
working american families getting relief
from student debt relief nope not going
to talk about that this plan is
definitely not going to talk about you
you going [ __ ] bankrupt over a
medical bill hell to the no it's not
there's no way in hell this plan talks
about anything americans want it'll
it'll [ __ ] talk about sexy green m
m's woke culture disney's woke and and
and there's being and fentanyl
being seized at the border
as if that's a bad thing
that's what it will be
about and we will crush it we will
politicize it
because folks we got him on the run and
we gotta lean into this we gotta lean
into this [ __ ] we really do
we can't stop now now that we feel like
oh well we're gonna take the senate we
probably gonna take the house nope
lean way into it
[ __ ] them
joe biden the president united states
called them fascist
he's leaning into rallying democracy and
you must lean into rallying democracy
too so have that strategic outrage
go use your power of your ballot and
engage in your democracy lean into it
lean way into it
because they're coming for your way of
life
and they're doing it in all sorts of
crazy ways and i have someone on the
show today that wants to talk about how
that is happening what is happening
you've noticed i
i hear lately
the cheeto dust mobster the former guy
has just absolutely been going bonkers
on fraud social
i mean some of these [ __ ] these
little posts that he does i mean you
can't even hardly read the son of a
[ __ ] they're so [ __ ] crazy and out
there but the one thing that is
significant that a lot of people aren't
paying attention to is he's been
retweeting a lot of q anon stuff it's
almost like to me and maybe we'll ask
our guest here
it's it's almost like to me
what donald trump is trying to do
is trying to really
reinvigorate
these conspiracy theories reinvigorate
this stochastic type terrorism to try to
get not just not just the oath keepers
and the proud boys but just average
everyday delusional americans who
believe this queuing on stuff
to get them to save him because you
remember in december of 2020 when he
knew he lost the state certified the
votes those votes were going to come to
washington
they were looking for the electorate the
electorate college in washington but
they couldn't find it
but when they when the vote came on
january 6 for them to certify those
states votes he was calling on those
people he was so desperately wanting
them to save him from indictments to
save him from not being president
because he knew the risk he knew it and
that's what he's doing again when he's
cat-calling these [ __ ] delusional
crazy q and honors
is he setting this up
to where
he can get them
to save him and we're going to talk to
jim stewartson right here
about this issue
when we come back we've i'm going to
talk about his film we're going to talk
about his film that he has on q anon you
have to go watch this film the link is
down in the description so after the
show go check it out you can also check
out his sub stack but stick around we're
gonna talk to jim right after these
messages don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime please donate now
because those trump supporters you just
saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
a very special guest
you know we like to serve the tweety
treats and journey trends i used to
retweet him but you can't retweet this
guy anymore
you cannot retweet this guy anymore he
is absolutely unretweetable
because he's been
jim stewartson how are you
i'm good man i'm good despite the fact
that you can't retweet me well you know
it happens it happens it happened you
it's your name
you were banned from twitter but you've
got this film and i want i think you
sent it to me a couple weeks ago um
several weeks ago
and
this thing is a great film it's about
what is about an hour long i think it's
45 minutes 45 minutes so it's a quick
watch but you really break down in the
film this q anon thing but i thought it
was so appropriate to have you on not
just to talk about this film but you've
been following these q and honors for
for a long time now since i think before
um the
2016 election was over you were
following some of these q and honors um
what and it wasn't really queuing on
them they've always rebranded right this
right-wing thing always does this
rebranding and these conspiracy theories
they always rebrand as they try to
regain do you think that's what trump's
doing with the with fraud social do you
think that's what he's doing is kind of
trying to rebrand the q anon
uh absolutely i mean he's not even
trying to rebrand it right i mean trump
social is basically just q and on
uh there's really not much else going on
there except for mega propaganda
right and you're right that it was the
significant thing that trump did was
just re retreat uh two drops like
straight q drops right he retweeted a
lot of other people
uh who were kind of queuing on
propagandists many many times hundreds
of times when he was you know president
of the united states amazingly
uh but to my knowledge he had never
retweeted just a raw cue drop before
this one was a particularly uh vile one
uh q drop 11 i think was was the one
and uh uh so it's significant that he's
just
directly talking straight to um q anon
victims is what i'll refer to them as
one i took a screenshot of one of his
his repost or whatever the [ __ ] they
call it over on fraud social but um when
he reposted this one it it has a really
long
um
uh letters you know and it says
um and i forget what the phrasing is but
it's their code we watched mike flynn
do this um this oh thing what what is
that what the hell is that thing that
they do um where we go one we go all is
that what is that what they say
uh it is what they say and it is what
mike flynn raised his hand to
on
[ __ ] july 4th right 2020. this is a
former general who's taking the oath to
our country
absolutely he still has three [ __ ]
stars on his chest which do not belong
there
um so so let me let me let me like not
bury the lead mike flynn's cue
right literally so that is who q is
that's what you're saying
uh that is what i'm saying mike flynn
has been um running basically psyops on
america
as you mentioned since the 26th before
the 2016 election
so what what i have done over the last
two years is sort of track
the entire progression of this you know
psychological warfare operation
um that has brainwashed a third of the
american public
if you look at what's going on out there
you look at the polls
and literally uh a third of the country
has
completely delusional beliefs
and that is a result of a sustained
psychological warfare campaign
led by
retired lieutenant general mike flynn
it started with pizzagate and all of
that stuff he cooperated with wikileaks
julian assange roger stone guccifer all
of that [ __ ]
that was run by an operation called
maga3x
maga3x was started at the rnc at the
republican national convention in 2016
that was the convention where mike flynn
said lock her up
they started this project called mega 3x
and we have documentation about how it
all worked
and they ran the operations that started
pizzagate that
you know hillary is is sick she's
mentally ill all of those sort of memes
and operations will run out of this
this group called mega 3x which was
started incidentally by peter thiel
mike flynn jeff gaseah who's peter
thiel's white supremacist henchman
and jack posobik and a bunch of other
you know white supremacists
um and mega3x then after after they
successfully
stole the 2016 election through what
mike flynn calls digital soldiers
after that was done
they when mike flynn got uh pinched
for talking to the russians and then
lying about it to the fbi
that's when q anon started
because mike flynn couldn't talk
he couldn't talk because he pled guilty
literally the week after q started was
when
mike flynn pled guilty
and then guess what happened after mike
flynn got his pardon
that was the q's last q drop in december
of 2020. so you're saying
he could talk at that point
yes q was literally the period of time
where mike flynn could not talk
it talked for him well
that's what he was but it's re-emerging
here gabe uh
we've got jim here um
welcome gabe this morning um
and and we watched
cause you bring up mike flynn jim and
gabe watched a a little clip that you
made a while back
and
this clip had a cult leader i forget
what her it's i forget what her name is
elizabeth claire profit that's it that's
it profit they even
they even go as far as calling
themselves profit like changing their
name to the to profit i mean why
wouldn't you right i mean why wouldn't
you but no i think that's actually that
that was her husband's name and and oh
really actually yeah so that's just
happenstance
yeah you know and they
i i figured
i looked deep
i looked deep back yeah i actually know
uh her son sean prophet
who's who's a great guy and and you know
has
been speaking out
against it for for a long time
um but yeah i found uh a
that mike flynn uh was reciting
literally
word for word a
cult prayer
from the 80s from this cult
called the church universal and
triumphant which was led by elizabeth
claire prophet
and mike flynn was reading
from it and having
a christian church
read it back to him and this is an
occult prayer by a fascist cult leader
who's spewing theosophy which is this
you know
propaganda from you know the late 1800s
that has infested a whole lot of
conspiracy theories
well i've got your um it's called is it
called american mine [ __ ] is that what
the um that's it that's the dock yeah
that's the docks i've got it uh pulled
up here i want to play just the first
few minutes here jim so we can show the
folks what this film's about but then
we'll talk about it on the other side
let's let's play it here just for a bit
[Music]
there's a voltaire quote
if they can make you believe absurdities
they can make you commit atrocities
in a nutshell
that's what this is there was a new
phenomenon this week something called q
anon what exactly is q anon and
why is it making headlines now here we
go
god bless america humanoid was a perfect
storm
they had set this thing up since 2017
it created this huge radicalized
set of people
then the pandemic comes in retreat
tonight seeking isolation in the face of
the coronavirus the federal government
is taking new steps forward to fight the
panhandle president trump flanked by
major ceos and his task force announced
a national emergency and suddenly you've
got
100 million more people online well as
of today all but a handful of states
have issued stay-at-home orders a
shitload of time on their hands this
comes as alabama and missouri just
joined 40 other states that are urging
people to stay home that covers nearly
95.
there is concern fear will turn to panic
store shelves nationwide are dwindling
or totally empty like when i started
this and i saw what i saw
i told people i was like you guys
you don't understand
will you [ __ ] listen to me please
there are mounting questions now over an
alleged plot to overthrow michigan state
government and kidnap the weather
exactly what's gonna happen
[Music]
look at how they're driving
it was difficult to be that crazy guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i have been trashed and harassed and
trolled and
[ __ ]
lied about
because no one wants to hear this
[Music]
well jim there you have it uh american
mindfuck um
thanks for sharing it with us because
it's a great film and i'm i've watched
it twice um once in regular time and
then once sped up because i wanted to
re-watch it i wanted to re-watch it
because you have so many good things in
there
that i think will resonate with people
about
how this happened and really the perfect
timing with the unknown pandemic that
was coming during the election year um
it really played into the hands here but
you mentioned in the very beginning of
this a quote from voltaire can you break
down why that is so important here
um
yes
so the the fundamental thing that's
going on here again is is literally
psychological warfare they are
brainwashing people
right
the the reason why there's
so many people
uh that don't seem like themselves right
you hear this all the time like my aunt
i don't even like who who is this crazy
lady who's talking about you know rept
reptilians and [ __ ] like whatever
the brainwashing happens to be right
um it comes from um psychological
warfare it comes from brainwashing
people and brainwashing's been around
for a long time but it used to require
that you take somebody and put them in
like a compound right like in waco or
in jonestown or wherever you had to
isolate them and insulate them in order
to
shut off enough of the outside
information
to to
to you know effectively brainwash them
it's not like that and the internet
right it's not like that anymore
um with social media because you can get
pounded by this information
and that get that has been weaponized it
has been systematically
uh weaponized into a brainwashing system
i i agree i agree with you i think the
algorithm can isolate you right in the
information that you're reading
whatever whatever whatever
um social media website you're reading
that algorithm can isolate you from
other information me and gabe have
talked about this several times you know
the algorithm isn't the the enemy it
really is like garbage in garbage out
kind of thing exactly
and that and that so so once these
people start to digest this stuff the
algorithm goes well this person's
reading this [ __ ] so let's feed them up
more trash and they'll read more trash
and stay on our website right so that
because the intention of the algorithm
is not the inherent evil
it's
the people who are using the algorithm
to what you say brainwash which i think
that's what's happening because i've had
relatives that have
fell and fall to this and they don't
even know what's
they
skewing
on
know they have no idea like they're
saying these things they'll say stuff to
me i'm like what you know that's queuing
on stuff they're like no
no i i read that on facebook like
yeah you read it
right q itself said in in 2020 stop
calling a q a stop call stop talking
about cues stop de-brand it
like literally cue date those
instructions
um you know right before the election
like stop talking about queue they
they've kind of sniffed it out and
they're they're using it as a label so
stop talking about it like that and they
basically just transformed it to the big
lie
so
so
this this guy ron watkins right that
yeah you know people have been
claiming his cue which he told the guy
ran for a congressional seat got his ass
kicked
he had to loan his own campaign 95 000
in order to get like three points that
[ __ ] is not q and anybody who
thinks he is is getting misled by bad
actors and i'm just telling you that
[ __ ] straight up
well
i was gonna say the other thing is is
because there's the hbo documentary and
i think a lot of people
have been misled in that way because
there was that ambiguity of he kind of
made it seem like he was the leader and
then the documentary was like well
guess we got the answer and then
everyone yes that's it and now everyone
says like oh yeah ron watkins yeah
that's that q guy that's that q guy he
was the one who ran in arizona oh yeah
yeah this that like mike lindell you
know all this stuff
and then you know i mean it's one of
those things where it's like it seems a
little bit more nuanced than just ron
watkins right it's not only more nuanced
ron watkins ran the website
that's it
he ran 8-chan he was the administrator
of 8-chan so that little moment where he
gets caught or whatever ron watkins
knows everything
he knows everything right he was there
he he worked with this this woman tracy
diaz aka tracy beans to move q from
4chan to 8chan he cooperated with that
he said he basically had qsa were i'm
only going to post on 8chan now forever
and always which was a huge mistake by
the way but but they they said that
because ron watkins took ownership of
the the place where q posted
but that is a very very very different
thing from ron watkins's queue ron
watkins didn't write q drops he didn't
strategically figure out how to mind
[ __ ]
30
percent of america that was not ron
watkins he was just a [ __ ] who ran
the horrible website that you ran on
the guy who was who was operating it was
mike flynn with steve bannon and roger
stone and peter thiel and all these
[ __ ] monsters
um who are
intentionally trying to cause chaos in
america so that they can cause
an apocalypse and you know pick up the
pieces uh you know in their white
supremacist fantasy world
that's what this really is there was a
there was a video that i watched this
morning which i was like oh my god this
is gonna be great uh having jim on
because in the last several weeks
um trump and his allies have been trying
to stoke this
stochastic terrorism um through their
little their little hey there's gonna be
violence if this happens hey there's
gonna be a civil war if this happened
you know wink wink like hate another
insurrection type [ __ ] right
but that br that didn't go very well and
the reason why is because democrats
didn't just go like oh they're just
being
silly
democrats like you [ __ ] terrorists
and and they really and joe biden leaned
into this and they really had to back it
off so much so that you have videos like
this that are coming out and i believe
this is an effect of this where they're
trying to what you said rebrand right
they rebranded from this to q and on
from q and on the big lie and now that
people are like you q and honors you
republicans you moglodites are [ __ ]
dangerous and you're violent and you
want to overthrow our democracy they're
trying to rebrand again right and that's
what this social media post is from
whoever this
lady is um but i think more than who she
is is more important of
listen to the script she's saying
because it feels like to me
she's heard this somewhere and she's now
repeating it into a social media post
listen
so as the midterms get closer there's a
couple of things that is patriots we've
got to keep in mind
one is that the deep state really wants
to
trigger and set off patriots
to entice or provoke them into violence
so so and i'm going to pause it a couple
times here because there's a few things
that she says that i want to make sure
we we we talk about before it [ __ ]
seeps into people's minds because it's
all complete [ __ ] number one
um this is this cat call for terrorists
as patriots right
they've totally they've totally taken
this word patriots uh under their own
wing and like yeah people who hate the
united states who love trump who want to
overthrow their government their
patriots like what the [ __ ] are all
fascists do that right right it's it's
it's national nationalism uh is that
always a cloak for fashion well
christian nationalism like national
socialism you know those socialist nazis
who weren't socialists at all i mean
it just it um it's it's it's par for the
course for fascists to do this and to
try to set up a fascist state the other
thing the other thing that she says here
is that she brings up the violence
almost immediately um right and that's
really what she's trying to say is don't
commit violence because they say we are
violent and listen to what she says
after which
it seems like projection let's listen
and no matter what happens
we can't allow that to happen
we must follow the rule of law we must
use our voting power we must write our
legislators we must we must stand up and
say no when appropriate
no matter what happens whether trump
gets indicted or even if he gets
arrested or worse
we cannot resort to violence we cannot
become what they are
so i mean you gotta i mean you gotta
love the projection okay right i mean
the party is
i mean i will say this you gotta hand it
to the republican party and trump
because they are professionals when it
comes to projection and hypocrisy they
will whether it's
uh fascism it's uh you know being sexual
predators with the economy whatever it
is
they will be like oh we can't be like
them
it's and it's like they're it's like
they're delivering the speech in the
mirror right like in an unironic fashion
they're practicing
talking to themselves but it really is
them saying it to themselves like we're
the problem we are the actual issue but
we can't be like them and them is us
because i'm pointing at you which is me
and we're the pro like
that's what it is exactly so so the the
the super power that all these
[ __ ] have is shamelessness
right
seriously like sociopathy psychopathy
which is what all these guys are
sociopaths or psychopaths or some
version of have no empathy whatsoever
that gives them the ability to be
completely shameless and just live 40
000 times or however many times that
trump did you know for four years right
like
he doesn't care it doesn't affect him at
all that other people know he's lying he
doesn't care it doesn't matter because
it's just about you know
um
his
him
and so what she's doing in my opinion is
is saying
you know wink wink not not uh there's
gonna nudge nudge there's gonna be
violence but it's their fault
right well and i think i think she's
saying that like she's doing the wink
wink nudge nudge not not thing like hey
he's gonna get indicted he's gonna go to
jail and they're the ones when violence
happens they're the ones to blame like
you're saying is that is that what
you're saying here is that she's saying
yeah totally yes right and i'm seeing it
everywhere so
it seems like a script does this seem
like a script to you this is 100 she's
reading she's reading yeah like i mean
she's obviously reading from
the other thing that makes me think of
is is how
it is the self-fulfilling prophecy right
they're like guys these guys are we
don't we don't want to be violent but if
they make us violent then that's not on
us right that's on them
and it's that conversation you you hear
the same thing with uh
um with charlie kirk right on fox news
and he's like joe is cheating or uh
joe biden is calling us fascist and he's
like oh if they really want to call us
fascists like we can call him something
even worse and it's like
you are now being like there's a light
that is being shined on that group of
people to expose them for who they
really are and what they really believe
in and those people are now saying well
okay well now that you've put the light
on us and you're saying that we're this
thing then i guess we'll just be the bad
guy we've just got to be the bad guy now
and what the reality of it is is like oh
[ __ ] we've been exposed and now our only
play is either to double down on us
actually being fascist or
retreat and try to rebrand into
something else
right yeah they're not retreating yeah
right that like pedo hitler remember
that trend oh yeah right after this is
right away right well i mean i mean
that's that's the thing is is that it's
always projection but listen here
because the gas lining in the projection
gets even worse it gets it gets it gets
even darker it gets even darker here the
projection in the gas light listen
because if we do if we give them any
reason
they'll they'll round us up in large
numbers they're dying for the chance to
either arrest us or to
bust us off at the fema camps and will
never be seen again so just don't give
them that satisfaction
fight
but peacefully
the second thing is is that
if if there is a scary false flag and uh
i'm pretty sure there's going to be
something that's going to scare people
keep in mind
everything is going as planned
so here's this other
she says she says that she projects the
thing about fema concentration camps
like look it's not hard to crowd you
people up all you gotta do is promise
your orange deity will appear in a
cattle pasture and you dumb
[ __ ] were all crowded there
it's not hard to crowd your sheep up it
really isn't and it's not hard to spot
you [ __ ] to know how dumb you
are we don't need to we don't we i
i really honestly i believe in free
speech jim i believe in freedom of
expression and i think any dumb
[ __ ] that wants to put on a make
america great
again hat so i know they're a stupid
bastard i welcome that that would be
great if you felt that way about the
rest of america that you hate america
and you're so [ __ ] un-american that
you would wear that nazi hat i would i
will i will gladly
welcome you to wear that so i know not
to
get near you because you're a dumb buck
but this lady here this the saddest part
about this whole thing
is she really like you said earlier has
been brainwashed this isn't like this
lady is some kind of [ __ ]
q anon operative that's trying to trying
to push this great scheme and trying to
you know
get liberals in a position this lady has
been completely brainwashed she believes
this [ __ ] that's the actual effect
that's the effect that steve bannon
donald trump uh donald trump jr
michael flynn all it's sydney powell all
these [ __ ] traitors
mike lindell
all these people that's the effect that
they want is someone like her believing
this garbage so much so that she'll make
a [ __ ] video repeating this absolute
gaslighting absolute nonsense to make it
look benign right because when someone
sees this
go ahead go ahead it's a requirement for
them to be propagandists right to not
only consume propaganda but to to then
reproduce it
that that's part of part of what's so
[ __ ] pernicious about it is that in
order to be accepted into the community
in order to get that sort of the the
social love bombing effect which is a
requirement for this kind of
brainwashing
um you you got to reproduce the
propaganda you got to be part of the
team you got to be part you know on the
on the you know right side
uh in order to prove yourself and it
just increases the level of of
engagement which increases the depth of
of the undue influence which is the sort
of more proper term for for brainwashing
um and and i also want to say something
about free speech real quick
uh
free speech that hurts people is not
free
the person who's getting hurt is [ __ ]
paying for it
right and so so the the people like
trump and bannon and and especially mike
flynn who are out there you know
claiming free speech when what they're
really doing is intentionally
um you know
psychologically hurting people
that's [ __ ] not free speech because a
lot of people are paying for it both the
people who are getting hurt themselves
and their loved ones right well and
that's a good point because i would
almost bet just looking at this lady um
that she's probably somewhere in the
midwest um
she seems like she probably has a child
that um that has went through college
and she had to co-sign on big ass loans
um you know federally subsidized loans i
would imagine that she lives on she gets
a social security check maybe she has a
teacher's retirement or something i'm
just guessing here and i but i would
imagine she has medicare and these sorts
of things and if you really sat down and
went like hey let's talk let's not talk
about crazy theories let's talk about
what your community can do for you and
what what what help you need in your
community should be like my community
you me at my kitchen table well number
one my medicare is too damn expensive my
social security's not high enough i'm
terrified that people are going to take
it away from me my damn kid is is up to
their eyeballs so much so in college
debt that the son of a [ __ ] still lives
with me and he and and they got a great
job because of the degree but it still
doesn't pay worth of [ __ ] to pay back
the student loans they don't have
[ __ ] health care because they can't
afford it so we've got that risk going
on i mean it just on and on and on it
could go right and you could sit down
and talk to these people and that is
what i think democrats have finally
started to come to the table to do to
unwind all this because
are you in agreeance that democracy is
the thing that can unwind this because i
truly believe that because you just
mentioned free speech and and i'll push
back on you a little bit i believe that
um we do have to we do have those
dangers because we have that liberty um
but what we have to do as citizens of a
democracy is participate and engage and
it can stave off some of that so do you
think democracy real true democracy
where people are engaging not just again
marking a ballot but talking to their
their community members their family
their fellow parishioners their
colleagues and having these
conversations do you think democracy is
the thing that can unwind this
um well democracy is the thing that this
is attacking right
so it's it is yes and no
the the issue
uh the issue is that
what what is
the effect of this is that democracy is
being eroded right both from the top
down they got a [ __ ] russian puppet
in there for four years to destroy it
from the executive down
and now they're doing all this local
action has a national impact which is
what mike flynn's like slogan is which
means that they're going to all these
school boards and local election boards
and trying to destroy the fabri and law
enforcement very importantly right
they're doing this constitutional
sheriff's thing where they're literally
getting entire police forces on on
you know the wrong team
so so
for me
yes democracy is absolutely
um
something that can fix this but the
thing that can really fix this is the
[ __ ] rule of law
that is fundamentally what this country
is is a a place where we all agree to
live by certain laws and so what needs
to happen is these [ __ ] who are
committing crimes who are spies and and
traitors to this country who are
planning insurrections who are creating
these these psychological traps for for
people those [ __ ] need to go to
prison and when they do the rule of law
will have uh will have saved our our our
country and then we can start to
actually exercise our democracy because
it's very difficult to exercise their
democracy correctly when it's being
attacked by all these bastards well
thank you for coming to make that talk
yeah yeah well rule speaking of rule of
law i got a clip here um boy you led me
right into
um the rule of law throwing down the
hammer um what it seems to be i think
it's six counts is what i'm counting
that he was charged with this morning um
this is this is great this is one of the
greatest piece of footages that you'll
see in a couple weeks this is steve
bannon still trying to play the victim
as he walks into the the courthouse here
and listen to the lady at the end oh no
i don't know who she is but god bless
her she's great
on the very day the mayor of this city
has a delegation down on the
take a step back
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you greasy two-bit grifter i don't
know who she is someone please send her
a bouquet of [ __ ] flowers somewhere
ah that lady that the lady deserves
lunch free for the rest of her life holy
[ __ ] i mean you gotta you gotta hand it
to to steve bannon he can launder money
but somehow he can't launder his own
clothes like the guy is a he is a slob
everybody just keeps putting clothes on
top he's like i got a shirt i got a polo
i got a button up i got a jacket like
i've never seen i've only seen like
three outfits it's like a striped shirt
with a camo jacket it's this all black
multiple shirt thing like he's just he
puts on all the shirts at the beginning
of the week and then takes them off or
he just adds them on every day but every
time he's made an appearance in like
professional
kind of uh an outfit it's always been
this i'm wearing a black shirt on top of
a black shirt on top of a black shirt
with a black jacket you know it's
that's never been washed never been
watched yeah yeah here is here's the
spiro agnews ghost as it uh tweeted from
earlier it says breaking steve bannon is
charged in uh new york with two counts
of money laundering three counts of
conspiracy and one count of scheming to
deep fraud now this sounds like like
trump org in general right like two
counts of money laundering three counts
of conspiracy this is like their motto
like they got it written down somewhere
that this is what they're doing but
there's something there's something else
uh i don't know if anyone remembers this
but back in 2020 that when the build the
wall was uh
was um
was started right they were fundraising
for the program you mean i mean this
actual one that he's been doing this
actual one right that's connected to i
think it's what fisher
uh
well yeah there's still there's still
people that are federally charged with
this that right didn't pardon he just
pardoned steve bannon because
you know
so so i so what i was saying was i don't
know if people remember the fact that
back in 2020 trump actually gave his
blessing
to
fisher industries and steve bannon to
build the wall he actually personally
tried to and repeatedly tried to lobby
for
uh
1.2 billion dollars to go to the wall
that was down there because of course
you know trump his family wall is
falling down and he can't get that thing
up and and and and have anything that
lasts long right
i mean all of that [ __ ] is just falling
apart where now we have to invest more
money to actually repair the damage that
he did by building a wall
but in doing so like he gave his
blessing to a private group that was
fundraising he's like yeah do it do it
and then tried to lobby money to this
exact same group so it's not surprising
one that this group is you know
obviously getting investigated and
indicted for fraud and money laundering
but like the fact that trump our
president at the time had his hands
mixing around in that pot of frogs
his tiny hands his tiny hands well you
know i actually um yeah
steve bannon's lawyers have produced a
picture here of uh his response to the
charges the six charges that is brought
um and i just want to make sure people
people know that steve bannon
this is the i don't know i i i don't
know i don't know this is just the
picture that they're pretty close
man
i don't know who made this but [ __ ] it's
good you're telling me that's that's not
an arraignment photo right well this may
be this may be his booking photo here i
don't know i know somebody needs to put
some numbers
all right gabe don't do that whatever
you don't don't make this into a booking
photo for steve bannon and post it on
our podcast account
and too bad we can't tag jim on twitter
man oh man but uh no i i i love that
picture of steve bannon it's the best
picture of him um and here speaking of
pictures i don't know who this is but we
need to find her this is the lady um who
was uh who called him the greasy two big
grifter yeah two big grip hero
well she's uh she's taking over for bill
maybe you know bill the guy who the
whistle guy
no the guy that has a guy he's been
behind uh uh he was behind all these
guys
he was the one he was also the one that
was behind peter navarro oh yeah yeah
yeah he's the guy that's got the whistle
on the long side
but he's been doing it since like 2017
like like a long time
well because the reason why is because
he's in washington right it's amazing
yeah yes exactly he's in dc so this was
in new york so he someone wants to go so
it's a so so bill maybe bill reached out
i was like hey right right you do new
york
well it happens it happens well i i
think i think um justice is coming for
these folks and the other uh the other
news uh and i think we're gonna have
dakota adams on to talk about this uh
hopefully we'll be able to record
something with him soon about the oath
keepers news uh stuart rhodes
uh stewart rhodes uh is actually going
to have to go to trial i assumed because
most of the time when
a defendant
fires their legal team and gets a new
legal team that legal team gets time to
prepare and that's their case and the
judging army grants it the judge is like
nope that's enough of this [ __ ] no this
is a [ __ ] i want to try please stop
right no [ __ ] way you're not gonna
you're not you're not slowing it down so
we're gonna so we're gonna see this
trial start um for
uh for stewart rhodes the founder of the
oath keepers the
the person who was looking for a direct
line um to donald trump the day of the
insurrection to bring the qrf across the
potomac
um to commit violence
and actually overturn our government and
that is the thing so i think the rule of
law is coming for these people and me
and gabe have talked about these
classified documents that this [ __ ]
buffoon stole from us um and harbored
them down in in mar-a-lago no telling
who he showed them to or sold them to or
ate them i think he ate some of these
things i think he got hungry
there's a lot of empty folders
yeah i mean i'm sure he is you know
paranoid right i mean
of course why he's freaking out about
baron's room and and melania's drawers
and all that stuff like he is very much
paranoid about the fact of they got
something that i hid behind the xbox or
whatever it might be
and they took it and now it was in his
desk it was like you know well yeah yes
well i can't remember like this
the most sensitive [ __ ] was like right
there right
if i if i had to imagine what the layout
of these documents were in mar-a-lago
like we know like oh it was in the pine
hall room which is just kind of an open
area we we have uh his desk and this and
that right
it's almost like he was like setting up
for like an easter egg hunt right like
he just had these folders randomly he's
like oh it's behind the chimney or like
it's behind the couch or it's on the
ground and it's like oh looks like you
found it if you find it you get to keep
it right they're trying to cancel easter
they're trying to cancel easter they
won't cancel easter we will have an
easter egg classified document hunt here
at mar-a-lago jim thanks for joining us
do it here's what here's what i want you
to do i want you to plug your sub stack
and plug anything you want do a
shameless plug here um for the audience
tell them where to find you i've got
your sub stack and the movie link down
in the description so everyone after the
show go check those out but do a
shameless plug here jim
oh just uh come join me on my sub stack
i write frequently uh multiple times a
day uh about all these asshats
um and uh i i'd love for you to
check it out and and subscribe if you
like it
um and and please especially if you have
a chance take a look at my documentary i
think for a lot of people it's been
helpful um you know and there's a lot of
people who don't want you to see it so
that's probably the best reason to do it
well all those links are down
in the description below and definitely
don't just watch
the american mind [ __ ] share it with
some of your relatives that may have
fell prey to this q anon conspiracy
theories and this brainwashing that has
happened uh to our country jim thanks
for joining us come back any time my
friend um we we love having you here
we'll talk we'll talk to you soon my
friend everyone stick around we'll be
right back with the shitless roundup
we're gonna surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends
right when we come back stick around
don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part and blanket
specifically works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
january 6th and if you're one of the
other members of congress who also
helped with the attempted coup pardon
blanket will protect you too pardon
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
a hundred percent made in the usa don't
delay and get your pardon blanket today
for just 99.99
actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
jim stewartson
you have to go watch this movie again
the link is in the description below
don't forget after the show
go check it out
[Music]
give jim sub stack
a chance
he does write a lot on it every single
day i can attest to that so go down the
lincoln's down below for his subs deck
gabe what a great guess jim yeah i mean
he's knowledgeable about that
hi-fi like they know their [ __ ] i mean
they are you know they're in the
trenches
uh
you know i mean we all see it every day
online like we go through this stuff and
we see it um
but they really go through it and they
break it down you know they've got their
own podcast and he's got a sub stack and
so they
they are they're in the thick of it when
it comes to they get down to the details
like yeah we just skimmed the servers
right just enough to be like here's the
tldr right and they're like here's the
dissertation deep deep dives right the
deep state dive right the deep state
dive because we've
we've had heidi kudon
we've had hi-fi on about the trucker
convoy in canada um some of the
shenanigans that went on about the
payments there um and now we've had jim
stewart's and on so
the radicalized podcast i i i think
that's all you have to do to find their
youtube channel too is just type in the
right place but yes and we'll put that
oh i didn't put that in the description
but i will put it down below so um after
the show i'll put it in there so if
you're looking for that as well i'll put
their their link to their podcast so you
can go watch they i think they do it
once a week is um is they do their
podcast and they have special guests on
talking about uh right wingers around
the world so it's not they don't just
focus on here in the united states which
is mainly our show but they focus around
this right-wing movement all around the
world that's catching steam
um speaking of world news did you see
that the queen
doctors have said that they have concern
for their health i guess this morning um
it's all over the news queen elizabeth's
health is
of a concern
and some are saying that it's it's there
was no incident like she didn't fall or
something or she didn't have like a
stroke but she is 96 years old now i
don't really understand a monarchy i
don't really understand it i i we've
lived in a i've lived in america my life
in the midwest
and i mean the only the only monarchy
that i was a part of was my parents were
the king and queen right like that it
wasn't a democracy in our house like you
were the prince that's no no
no
no it wasn't a democracy i was a peasant
you oh you're just working in the
stables you know you're like you know
you had to work on a farm so like we
were okay so i guess that is pretty
close yeah
we were feeding the chickens um feeding
the the the bottle cash feeding the
cattle uh cut we we eated our house with
wood with wood stove so
i i now we had a bathroom we had running
water so that's good yeah and it wasn't
dirt floors there were actually wood
floors but you know that the point that
i'm trying to make here is that
that um i don't really understand
monarchies and i don't understand that
sort of thing and because we don't have
that culture here really right i mean we
got away from that
right we actually fought them to not
have them there was a crazy it was like
revolutionary it was insane really this
sounds like a war that you're talking
about it was pretty epic it was a it was
a big time it was a lot of battles okay
made up a big war right but it seems
like you'd want representation you know
i mean and away from a monarchy and that
might be why you do such a revolutionary
thing yeah yeah yeah you're like i want
my voice to be heard right they're like
oh [ __ ] this doesn't help us
now the the of course the uk is now a uh
parliamentary system so they have the
the parliament but the queen is still
like the figurehead right he's still on
the money right well i mean that's the
one thing i don't quite understand about
you know the the monarchy is right that
and and um
i think the reason why i think more and
more about this is because megan and
harry really walked away from that life
that
why do we let our country people make us
super duper rich because
we were cracked out of the right person
right like why why in the hell is that a
thing that because but again we don't
have that culture here so i don't really
understand it right but apparently if
something does happen the secession
is going to be her son um right is that
am i right in that i believe he's the
next one in line yeah right so unless he
abdicates i guess is the word that you
would use to
um give the throne but why would someone
do that at this point i mean there's no
real i mean it's really just pops and
circumstances are does the the actual
king or queen hold any kind of
real power over the uk because i thought
it was the prime minister in the
parliament there but yeah i mean like in
terms of like establishing law
i think i think the queen is just a face
i mean i could be wrong again i don't
live in that society so i don't know
what that's like and i'm sure if i did i
would know
more about the ins and outs you know uh
exactly how that'll work but
um
i'm watching i'm watching all four major
news
networks and it's that's the only thing
they're talking about that's it and it
feels like to me that the the public
position here is that
um yeah she's probably going to pass but
it seems like the back end of it's like
yes this is a definite thing because
they're covering the [ __ ] out of this um
this morning uh for queen elizabeth and
i i i actually
i i think she is a good leader i'm not
saying she's a bad leader i'm not saying
that monarchy shouldn't exist i think
it's a little crazy that we still have
this idea that um you know just because
you're born of a certain person and
certain thing but that's their culture
right that's their culture so well i
mean
i mean i'm not going to say that's not
true in america but there certainly is
that with an extent like you know
private companies will do that i mean
their nepotism obviously within right
certain power structures well i mean we
worship celebrities here i mean yeah
yeah even reality tv stars for crying
out loud but we i mean we certainly
don't have a system that say like if the
queen's gone then it's uh it's her son
uh charles right and if charles gone
then i think it would be
prince william because prince harry was
like
i defect yeah right me and megan were
not right
they think that's the case i think
that's the case and i think harry and
megan
um you know for whatever reason they
decided they didn't want to be part of
the monarchy i think they were also just
like we want to you know i and i yeah
it's totally respectful they're like we
just want to do this on our own we don't
want autonomy i mean they're like we
we don't want to have these obligations
we don't have to want to do the dog and
pony show we have to go around do this
do that we will you know
uh we will give up
our i think whatever the stipend was
we'll get home and this and that like we
just want to live a normal life you know
because i mean like you know just gotta
remember who megan is right i mean i
think when she was a kid she was like a
nickelodeon tv star too right so it's
like she's someone that is you know of
normal i guess average person status
well way more normal than than so yeah
you know prince jesus christ i mean i
can only imagine like if you're in that
for as long as you are growing up
there's a certain point either you you
buy into it and you're like yep i'm
waiting for that moment and i don't
really have to work ever in my life
or
you're like
nope not going to do this i want to do
my own i want to make my own i do not
want to have the crutch of
some uh monarchy behind me or some um
uh
some some royal family
uh
um someone on youtube spawning out here
charles will be the next king and i
think that's i mean i i i mean unless
something goes awry and he would again
and that's what i was saying i it'll go
it'll go charles and that'll go prince
william right because he's the next in
line right after him so
well and again that's it's not something
that happens here now the reason why i
bring this up the monarchy is because
that's literally what the the cheeto
dust mobster wants that's what his
family would like to have that's what
they were trying to do on january 6 is
to set up a monarchy but to not have a
democracy backing it because that is the
difference in the uk is like you said
with the legislator in the laws now the
people have still have a voice in what
their government is in their form of
government and who is in that government
um by the way of the vote by the way of
the ballot and democracy itself it's a
little different set up than ours but um
but it's still a democracy
uh there in and of itself so it's kind
of weird to me like how does that work
you know because i know i don't know
because that's literally i think what
donald trump wants is he wants like hey
i want to be the king and then you know
we can pretend that you have a democracy
and that's because he keeps talking
about on [ __ ] fraud social rights
that he wants to he wants them to crown
him king and redo the election all kinds
of well he said last week or the week
before oh my god he said you've got
three times in the last couple he was
like you guys have two options you
either make me president
or you redo the election god damn it and
it's like okay good luck with that right
uh because we have a democracy and well
because that's in our constitution not i
mean like there's nothing there there is
no and i think that's the reason why
he's saying it just what we were talking
about with jim is he's trying to rile
these people up right that had this
complete delusion that had no clue what
the [ __ ] constitution says that there
is no mechanism
none that makes it to where you can redo
an election here because that is the
thing in the uk that does happen
their constitution does allow them
to re
trigger an election
that is something their form of
government has the capability of doing
ours does not because but i think that's
why he gets in this mindset like well
they can do it over there so we can do
it over here like yeah but that's not
how it works you just don't get to
[ __ ] [ __ ] ideas out on fraud social
and that be the truth no matter what you
call it right but that's i mean that is
how maggo works right like i've got a um
i thought i was going to get it last
night i was working on what was that
where about around the trump rally and
then my phone died and it
i'm so upset anyway i got to redo it but
that is something i actually talk about
which is like
trump goes out on this at this rally and
he says joe biden gave a very hateful
divisive you know um
just uh uh terrible speech right it was
awful he was attacking us you're an
enemy to state joe biden's the enemy
estate which is like holy [ __ ] the
projection on a guy right who literally
stole government classified government
documents and is being investigated for
violating the espionage act you're gonna
tell me that you
a traitor
are are not the enemy estate like
committing treason is not
saying hey look enemy in the state of
course not because they're going to
project as much as they can but it's one
of those things like at maggot rallies
it is always hateful it is always
divisive and that in itself unites them
together to say our anger toward others
is what will do this damage and they
will you know they will
say whatever do whatever and then you've
got trump who says
uh this is yes what was that is coming
your way i'm hoping to film it the rest
of it today and maybe release it today
but it'll definitely on the show
tomorrow so look out
um
but yeah it's you know trump uses these
rallies to say as you know as much as he
can
to divide separate make claims
outlandish lies like you talk about john
fetterman being a drug addict talking
about the 2020 election the georgia the
perfect georgia phone call these are all
things where he you know as much as he's
saying like oh well you got to make me
president
it isn't it doesn't add truth to
anything he says like everything he says
is a lie everything he touches dies
everything he is involved in is
literally investigated for fraud right
like this is his super pac is being
investigated by the doj
as a as a jan 6 probe right
around fraud which is
not surprising the [ __ ] thing was
tainted from the beginning i did not see
that coming yeah
but yeah i mean i mean we have we have
steve bannon being prosecuted are
surrendering to prosecutors today on six
counts um and those counts again i can
read them again here yeah are are
i thought i had them handy here yeah
you're there uh two counts of money
laundering three counts of conspiracy
and one count of scheming to defraud and
it's this that the wall scheme thing
that steve bannon's gonna go to jail for
that's the same thing that save america
is right same [ __ ] they were raising
money for legal funds
and didn't have that thing we already
know that the january six select
committee has already said
this thing that he says is an illegal
defense fund for the presidency is not a
thing there is none you're just stepping
in his pocket and so which brings me to
my next thing we got to go to the
because i want to show this video have
you seen this ad of lincoln project they
didn't copy you on there they didn't
steal this okay all right i did i did
see that donald trump uh was upset at
least oh he's pissed off he's pissed off
so let's do this let's go to the tweety
tweets and trendy trends let's surf
twitter
go to the shitless roundup start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to this [ __ ] list roundup when
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
oh boy i do wanna i just i do wanna
point something out because we didn't
get to mention it during the during the
segment with uh with jim i saw somebody
ask how many years is steve bannon
looking at right now
from what i've read he's looking at five
to 15 years
which uh
and that's in state prisons so yeah i
brought this up in the in the a block
the first 30 minutes
is that this is not connected to the
federal case that he's been convicted on
for contempt of congress he's waiting
sentencing for that that's got what a
year i think
well up to a year and a hundred thousand
dollars right right so so the the judge
likely will give him less than a year
and here's why is because he'll have to
serve every goddamn day of it yeah when
you get a federal sentence like that on
less than a year there's no good time
there's no getting out early you serve
every [ __ ] day
now and he hasn't served time yet he'll
probably get one day credit for him
being detained to be arraigned right and
he'll probably get one day's worth of
credit because he probably said i'm
surprised he showed up today by the way
i gotta i gotta be honest really i am
surprised that he showed up no he's a
[ __ ] he's there's no way this whole i'm
gonna fight it to the bitter
well yeah i know i mean we're still
waiting for it to be medieval but yeah i
was surprised like are you telling me
that a cowardly thing would be to to
give in i think a cowardly thing would
be to try to [ __ ] uh evade the law
right well that would be cowardly but he
steve bannon has better lawyers than
donald trump
and the reason why is because steve
bannon actually pays his attorneys
i mean that's so so he actually has he
probably actually steve bannon actually
has
some sort of legal defense inside the
courtroom and that's what steve bannon
knows here is that he can go outside and
yell and scream and say this stupid [ __ ]
and the judge really is going to pay too
much attention to it in the courtroom
because it's just fodder on tv um
especially if he has a good legal
defense
but the problem is the problem is like
with donald trump is the [ __ ]
says this [ __ ] in court like he's
writing his own motions and crown and
[ __ ] and he's really he's really pissed
off this morning i mean he is
he is upset at the [ __ ] lincoln
project like dude is big mad
at the lincoln project for dropping
truth
on his supporters via fox news uh here
is the
uh the post on fraud social
um if you want to
let me let me remove this banner here so
you can kind of read it here the
perverts and low lives
i don't know why that's capitalism why
is it again yeah i don't know what the
[ __ ] also why was that the voice you
went to
like the perverts and low lives well i
mean that sometimes when i read trump's
statements this is the voice that i read
it in because this is kind of who he's
talking to my friend
this is the people's
he's not talking to me well no he's not
talking to us he's talking to [ __ ]
boneheads out there that again have been
mind [ __ ] as jim put it on on this
website and others like facebook the
perverts and low lives
of the lincoln project are back on where
else fox news i don't know why he why
why does he add words where he doesn't
need he loves it i do this every once in
a while he loves the commas i'll add
words where i don't need them and and
sometimes when i read my tweets before i
tweet push the tweet button because very
rarely do i i don't know if anyone
notices that like when i tweet i write
it out and i push tweet i don't go back
and read the [ __ ] i push tweet
i'm tweeting so i push tweet but he adds
words here
you're so you're saying adds words just
so he can have commas is what you're
saying well i think you know a lot of it
he might suffer from the same thing you
do which is just like you it's a stream
of consciousness hey easy do you know i
put me in the same way i'm not saying
that you're the same person oh okay i'm
just saying that you have a similar way
like you were like yeah this dumb mother
like you'll be like this dumb m effort
and then you'll have like the two red
exclamation points yeah and you'll just
like quote tweet yeah i know i know
tony's
what his tweets are like uh yeah but it
is very much like yeah you'll be like
yeah [ __ ] and then you'll send it to me
and it's like ooh am i going to get
banned for this yeah every once in a
while i'll actually type out a tweet and
before i hit tweet i will screenshot it
in the draft send it to game and go hey
you think i'll get banned and you're
like yeah definitely i'm like sweet i'm
tweeting that [ __ ] like that
if you're saying yes i will get banned
that is something you're gonna get
you're gonna get to a certain point
where your account is reaching enough
people and someone is going to then be
like i am so upset by this tweet and
then you'll by my two red exclamation
points oh how offensive
i mean according to republicans those
exclamation points are
well they are red um he goes on grandpa
poopypants goes on to say here i thought
they ran away to an asylum after their
last catastrophic campaign with charges
made against them that were big time
sleaze as if he's never had big time
sleaze allegations against him epstein
taking teenagers to mar-a-lago for him
personally i'm just saying and me
getting many millions more votes in 2020
than i got in 2016. okay there was
higher turnout so yeah that's true but
you lost by 8 million [ __ ] yeah
and then he goes on to say i'm not sure
who paul ryan ranyan
is that he say it i'm not sure paul
ryan ryan
like it's phonetically like ryan ryan oh
oh i is he saying paul ryan he's saying
paul ryan but he spelled paul ryan and i
don't know if it was in is that
i don't know this is what's very
confusing about well now i now i'm
wondering is this a real person
no or
no because he says run fox only has high
standards for him okay i don't know why
he put quotes around trump i'm not sure
um for trump ads
but not for anyone else i i don't know
exactly what this sentence is saying i'm
not really sure i'm not really sure all
ryan run fox only has high standards
the paul
ryan
right run fox maybe
because paul ryan is on the board of fox
news yeah yeah he's on oh okay okay okay
well i would have probably put like
dashes or hyphens between this connected
all right so this is the paul ryan run
fox news only has high standards for
trump ads but not for anyone else got it
okay so he's saying that any ads okay
now i got a transfer
i had to read this a few times to really
get it okay so he's saying that anything
that's related to trump anything about
the big lie mike lindell all of that
[ __ ] spreading just misinformation
about the election and trump losing
or trump winning rather
they won't play them but they'll play
every other single ad they don't have a
they don't have a standard for anything
else just for anything well of course
because they don't want to get [ __ ]
sued they're already in a [ __ ]
lawsuit with dominion software which is
crazy because they have mike lindell my
pillow commercials all over fox again
oh they haven't back on fox yeah oh yeah
oh yeah but uh but it says it goes he
goes on to
to puke out of his pie hole here um the
perverts again capitalize perverts i
don't know why he's capitalizing
perverts here it seems weird um he seems
to have an affection for perverts should
not be allowed to quote false advertise
again the air quote thing not i don't
i don't understand
why he's putting air quotes on something
that he thinks is true
anyways um false advertise comma and fox
news should not allow it to happen and
then he says
see you in court
three examination points why is court
capitalized here
i don't know why
i have no idea i mean like here i know
how to write these things i don't know
why he does them right so i like i know
what word should be capitalized what
word should be in all caps you know what
what uh you know
uh buzzword should be used can i explain
why he does those things no i can't but
i can imitate them
well you sent me a tweet here is this
this is um is this rick wilson this is
rick wilson responding to trump's uh
whiny whining
this is not fair
no i'm sure rick has a uh well if you
went back well okay
we'll play we'll play that we're going
to play the ad i'm going to play it
again i'll let lincoln we're playing
we're playing the sequence of events out
of order but that's fine
hey what the [ __ ] man i'm playing them
in the exact order i want to play them
in
we're going to get to the ad here i'm
trying to hang the audience here on this
ad this is anticipation okay
anticipation here's rick's because he
didn't just tweet he made a [ __ ]
video
um that's you know that's showing
commitment rick says donald trump is
truthing again this is how you actually
use
error quotes but you know
and who's counting
so
one on rick he knows how to use air
quotes
most people do donald trump is truthing
that he's going to sue the lincoln
project uh i have words for him oh i
can't i can't wait i would imagine that
rick is gonna challenge him here
um but
let's let's see what says you rick
hey folks wanted to say hi really
quickly and to just give donald trump a
message since you threatened to sue the
lincoln project this morning
go for it
go for it [ __ ]
come at me
i can't wait we're we're delighted by
the thought that you would try to sue us
donald do it
do it
i double dog dare you you know when we
put up the billboards in times square of
jared and ivanka during the coveted
crisis at the end of the 2020 campaign
we received this letter from mark
casowitz donald trump's attorney and it
was this complete you know blustering
[ __ ] show oh we're all sort of sue you
we read it in the bane voice right
you're not going to sue anybody donald
you're not going to do [ __ ] you're not
going to do a goddamn thing you were
weak you were impotent you were flabby
you were sitting there in the bridal
suite at mar-a-lago or in the bridal
suite at bedminster grinding your gears
wondering why that the lincoln project
no matter how many times you tried to
kill us keeps coming at you you know why
we're here
in this fight for the long haul because
you are a threat to democracy you are a
threat to america you are a threat to
the republic you're a threat to the
constitution you're a thief of
classified documents you're a traitor to
this country you've tried to overthrow
this government and the system of our
peaceful transition of power and [ __ ]
you
we're here you're not we will keep
kicking your ass every single day so if
you want to try to sue us donald go for
it throw down let's go we can't wait you
won't do it because you are in fact as i
said previously completely impotent just
ask melania anyway
other than that it's a great day for
america steve bannon is in looking at
the inside of a jail cell once again
donald trump is raging in mara go [ __ ]
yourself for a bed
oh
rick come on the show [ __ ] come on the
show let's talk about this we got a few
things to talk about but we'll talk
about that first hey i'm i'm willing to
throw down on this guy wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on hold on hold on
what do we got what do we got we got
breaking news or something uh
this book did i just hold on what hold
on what's going on hold on i'm not
getting
are you getting a vision
are you getting yeah yeah yeah i'm
getting a vision i'm sorry hold on i
just saw somebody in the chat say that
the yes okay
the queen has passed away yeah so that
that is that is um what i was saying
earlier yes uh queen elizabeth dies at
the age of 96. uh cnn's reporting it fox
news is reporting it um all the news
stations here msnbc is reporting it so
they're all they're all reporting and
queen elizabeth has died i everyone kind
of thought that this morning because uh
the the spokespeople were kind of saying
oh it's
just not a big deal the doctors are just
concerned kind of i mean it was kind of
but everyone knew like i said like i
think the uh
the back channel talk was no she's gonna
pass today so it looks like queen
elizabeth ii
has passed away at the age of 96
um
70 years she was queen for 70 years yeah
that's crazy she was only 26 years old
when she became the queen of england
yeah that's crazy um and and and you
know if you if you think about the time
period because i was talking about this
earlier the time period that this queen
has
been a leader of a foreign power
and the foreign power that has had to
fight fascism
um
that that in and of itself is uh kind of
um kind of historic that she remembers
that time right
um she was right there
um as as the world had to fight fascism
and then she became the queen of the
country who
had to pick the pieces up after the
second world war so she has passed
and it looks like
uh her son prince charles
will take the throne i'm not sure how
that works either do they like
wait until a certain time or does it
happen right away and then they do the
official thing after i don't know i
don't know i don't know uh
sure i'm not really sure how that works
but um everyone is reporting again that
queen elizabeth ii has died at the age
of 96. and i actually i actually um i
think she is a great leader i think she
has a history of being a great leader um
i don't i i think it it probably is a
sad day for the uk and the sad day for
the world um that we as we watch the
queen of england who has been the queen
for 70 years pass away um
because she has been
such
um
a voice for people in the world and a
voice for democracy she has stood
um out of the way of democracy
in her country even though she is a
monarch
and she has been in power for 70 years
she let the people have their voice and
she let the government operate in the uk
now you know and i'm sure there's a lot
of bad a list of bad stuff that you
could say about the queen i mean this
whole i mean everything
yeah i was going to say right obviously
the the way in which they treated uh
right megan right uh obviously that was
i think complete [ __ ] but um
yeah but if you go back and you really
look at um how the monarchy is handled
it really feels like the handlers are
more in control of the public image
of the monarchy than the monarch itself
um and that's the pomps and circumstance
that's the [ __ ] that we really don't
understand like the culture of why
why
why folks in the uk
um still
think this is a good thing to have a
monarchy i mean i'm sure there's a you
know a lot of them that don't but um
it's just it's just a different culture
that we don't have here so we really i
don't understand it um it's confusing to
me and i've tried to listen this morning
and a couple of people talking about it
and i'm like i still don't [ __ ] get
why what the hell
um
you would
hold up a monarchy for but that is i
think at this point it's more of just a
symbol it's an icon of what you know
what was
not is obviously because you know
they've got a parliament but uh it it
you know like
i think it's uh it's so entrenched
in
their society it is so much built within
their core that i don't know if you
could actually get away like you could
get a like out of it especially because
the family is still in existence you
know
uh to take that away i think would be
a very
divisive kind of
choice and i don't even know how that
would work right like how you if if
there was no family members you'd be
like all right cool there's like no one
there so we don't really have any but if
you got a queen uh her son
his sons
their kids right like the british family
is not ceasing to exist right they are a
royal power
at least in their kind of
worldly influence right as a figurehead
or as the the voice and the face of the
uk
um
but it is strange to us because again we
we fought a revolutionary war to get
away from the monarchy and the power of
the monarchy so it's very odd to us but
i want to go back to um so
it sounds like oh sorry i was just
reading an article from last year on uh
and political
uh politico and they were saying that
the question is not whether the uk will
abolish the monarchy once she dies but
the institution continues to enjoy broad
support so it's one of those things that
i guess you could
you could abolish the monarchy
it sounds like through the parliament
well i mean they did it in russia i mean
they did it in russia um but it sounds
like there's an overwhelming amount of
support so they wouldn't be able to do
that well because i think it's support
of pomp and circumstance not actually of
the power of the throne so but but we'll
we'll see i want to go back to um
um our democracy the uh lincoln project
here is the ad that rick wilson is
talking about in that video that donald
trump is so [ __ ] pissed off about and
when i show this if there's a reason why
i showed this in this order when i show
this you'll understand why the word
salad from donald trump and why the
great clap back from wilson let's watch
dear magga
we have some bad news
no not that he lost not that your little
coup attempt failed and its planners and
the attackers are going to jail
no
the really bad news is why trump told
you he lost why he set it up way before
the 2020 election
it wasn't voter fraud but it was fraud
trump told you the election was stolen
to rip you off to sucker you to take
your hard-earned money and shovel it
into his pockets
he spent it on himself not to take back
the white house
it was the biggest scam in political
history every dollar you sent him paid
to keep his shaky business empire and
lavish lifestyle going it was a suckers
game all along and you know who the
sucker is
it's you
bitching
and i don't know why he's so upset they
really didn't target him i think he's
upset because it may piss off a lot of
his supporters
i mean i think that's yeah yeah yeah
that's what he's really pissed off about
it's
it's the fact that
because
they attack
his supporters right and his supporters
and everything they believe in is so
ingrained within trump and what he says
then
uh
it's an attack on him right he's like
you're attacking the people that that
pay me you're attacking my piggy bank
right you're attacking the people who
push my lies
you are attacking me right there's like
this transit of property if you attack
them and they support me then you're
attacking me right
and it's
well it's the same thing that that
these morons have been saying that that
they're coming and it's steve bannon put
that out in a statement we read it
yesterday is they're not just coming
after me and president trump it's all of
us that they're kind of they right they
are they yeah right i mean we talked
about this like they gave me the virus
it's like no no who is they nobody gave
you [ __ ] man you did it to yourself you
exposed yourself
you got too greedy you flew too close to
the sun your [ __ ] wings burned up and
you flew and you fell back down to earth
right and now who's waiting but merrick
garland and the rest of his [ __ ]
merry band of prosecutors they're coming
after you and you're [ __ ] worried and
everyone else is merrick garland robin
hood is that what you're i think mayor i
think merrick garland is robin hood i
would be very curious to see and i'm
sure i'll like you know upset some
people
uh but i would love to like put a
collection of people who are like
merrick garland isn't doing his job
merrick garland is an actor and we've
said it on the show multiple times for
months we said there's a reason why it's
taking long because
just this case just investigating trump
from mar-a-lago is a very timed well
time sensitive but it's a very tight
locked [ __ ] nobody knew about anything
until trump was like they raided my
house no one would have probably known
about any more of this until maybe he
found out i was committing crime right
but at the same time like oh [ __ ]
they're investigating bannon they're
investigating trump for uh you know the
super pac they're investigating him for
jan six they're investigating him for
mar-a-lago and taking the documents
they're investigating all these other
people that are committing fraud either
they're
investigating the police officers who
who killed brianna taylor all of these
things at the same time everyone's like
oh you're not working fast enough
they are
a multi-faceted group who are
multitasking and doing a very good job
of not exposing or leaking these things
before
a search warrant is done or an
investigation has begun or when you find
out it's like oh yeah we already still
quite already brought together a grand
jury so this [ __ ] is moving
and so i'd be curious to see all the
people or all the posts online people
who were just very upset at the time to
be like he's not working fast enough
he's not doing this he's like dude
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on it's not
just about trump there's a lot of
justice to be served in this country and
i think that's why lincoln project made
that [ __ ] ad is because really at the
heart of the january 6 select committee
um and referring crimes or the
information that the doj gets that they
collected for the evidence i think the
two things that that trump is at risk
here and the trump allies are at risk
here is this [ __ ] credit card fraud
this credit card scam where he was
collecting millions of dollars for a
legal defense fund that didn't [ __ ]
exist
then on top of that
on top of that you have the state
electors and that investigation seems to
be probing and probing and probing from
the grand jury so i think those are his
two real
uh um criminal exposures in the january
6th but that's outside that's outside
and that's and that's also you know i
think there's another important thing to
to note here
is when people say what's the jan6
committee gonna do right what's what are
they gonna do what are they going to do
what what can they do
now you could argue that
you know
obviously they don't have any
power
to charge or indict someone
but
even around
jan six and the data collection and
evidence categorization and and sifting
through all this stuff they are working
with the doj now but they are doing so
much of a detailed oriented job for the
doj to say like here are the documents
here are the videos here are these
people cross reference we've got a
[ __ ] data matrix where it's like
here's this person and this out this
person this organization crossover and
here's the day and here's what they did
and this is the money and blah blah blah
and now the doj was like great we've
been able to focus on this other stuff
and you've been able to provide us this
information so that we can now move
forward and actually have a case right
they're watching
the hearings live so for anyone who says
what's the point of the jn6 committee
they're not doing anything
it's it's it's completely wrong they are
doing they have done so much already
they've already uh educated the public
on what trump which is what they need
exactly
exactly in opinion and not only that but
they've also uh you know worked with and
provided that evidence that they've
collected and organized to the doj so
they make their job easier to say great
we [ __ ] got them let's round them up
right and not only that but obviously
he's under investigation for multiple
things in multiple jurisdictions for
multiple things that he did one i think
that the the most important part there
is the january 6 select committee as
much as they're interested probably in
the records that he had at mar-a-lago
because some of them could be uh some of
those records that they're looking for
that are missing from like the white
house logs that the january six
committee would be very interested in
but i think the thing is is that
those two things are not
those indictments and those
investigations don't have anything to do
with each other because donald trump
chose not to participate in to obstruct
nara and doj to get our government
documents back which only led him in a
position where he's committing crimes
after he's present not while he's
president we're right but he still
thinks he has the capability of the
presidency i don't know it's all
it's all i mean it goes back to earlier
where he was like
i should be the president and if you
don't make me the president then we
should redo the election and it's like
nowhere
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
you're not the ruler you're not you're
you're not a dictator right you know
you're impotent like rick said
well here is speaking of people who want
to be president
the right wing is freaking the [ __ ] out
gabe they are freaking
the [ __ ] out
about someone being president of the
united states
um apparently
aoc was on the cover of gq which yeah
we'll get to that yeah
but um and this tweet here democrats end
up on the cover of gq republicans end up
on the fbi's most wanted list that's
hilarious but here is the cover
here's the cover that aoc is on they are
freaking
i mean dude they are doing 20 minute
segments on this [ __ ] cover
it's amazing how much they are bothered
by this when it's like
shouldn't you guys be doing your jobs
well should you actually be serving the
american people well i mean
but the right-wing media because they
see this as she wants to be present and
i guess she gave an interview with them
and there's an interview on the inside
of course it's a [ __ ] magazine yeah
um you know and they're really pissed
off that gq which is supposed to be a
man's magazine has a beautiful woman on
the front of it what the [ __ ] are you
talk like they're confused by this
they're like why is the woman on the
cover gq like what are you talking about
it's a men's quote-unquote men's
magazine with a beautiful woman have you
ever heard of playboy or hustler or what
are you let me educate you
sports illustrated have you ever seen
the back rack of a 7-eleven the [ __ ]
that they don't sell you right or like
they do sell you but the thing that you
cannot get just right willy nilly jay
gray
don't understand how these [ __ ] right
wingers how they even come up with this
nonsense that a a woman a beautiful
woman shouldn't be on the cover of a
men's magazine like dude go tan your
balls a little more this is the same
group by the way this is the exact same
group when they talk about oh man we
should have melania back in the white
house i miss having a first lady who was
so beautiful
and they now remember they are the same
people
that shared her naked photos and be like
now that is a first lady i can get
behind so don't give me this [ __ ]
where they're like oh you guys this is
not fair
beautiful woman's on the cover gq and
then meanwhile they're like oh look
melania's naked oh yeah [ __ ] that's so
good you know
well i mean that's it it's par for the
course yeah here is a fox news
i think this is from the five
jessie water jess is it jesse waters yes
jesse waters that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
uh
tucker carlson light here
chimes in on why aoc shouldn't be on the
cover listen the squad taking over the
democratic party and taking over men's
magazine covers aoc getting a new
fawning cover story from gq which is
still around which calls her the
political voice of a generation and the
right wings night terror in the flesh
the radical congresswoman opening up
on her own shot at the presidency but
she says
the country is too sexist for it to
happen
he just he can't handle i mean she's not
wrong
right right why i mean i mean we saw and
this is an example this is a this is a
prime example oh she complains that the
the country is sexist so they won't uh
uh they won't
elect a female president oh i wonder why
jesse waters as you give this thing
attempted women on
attempt at delivering the news you're
like oh dude aoc dude who the [ __ ] cares
she was on the cover trump was on time
magazine for other [ __ ] and you didn't
complain you were so happy well they did
when he was on time magazine for crime i
tweeted well i tweeted from the pod
account i tweeted jesse waters is jelly
that aoc is on the cover of gq maybe
maybe he should tan his balls more i
mean really this this seems like this
[ __ ] weenie ass
these moglodite [ __ ] where they're man
they just
why are you crying that aoc is prettier
than lauren boober why are you doing
that because if if if lauren bobert was
on the [ __ ] cover of
pewd monthly oh god oh it's she
beautiful oh i loved it
the walls would be covered in
oh my god jesus christ but yeah they
will you know they're like oh look
lauren bobert did it better than aoc
it's like
okay first off there are two people that
are representatives who are obsessed
with with uh with aoc one is her stalker
which is marger taylor green and two is
her wannabe
clone copy which is lauren bobert
everything that she does a uh you know
everything aoc does lauren bobert tries
to do right
they want to have debates and the
funniest thing is i think it was a few
months ago where they're like oh how do
you how do you respond to the requests
for having a debate with you know lauren
bob or march of the green she's like i
don't know they're a bit obsessed with
me it's a little unhealthy uh
and that [ __ ] pisses them off because
she's like look i'll acknowledge you to
the extent of saying that you're [ __ ]
crazy and you're a stalker and i need a
restraining order from you
but i won't acknowledge you and take you
seriously as a representative who
actually represents her constituents in
her district which neither of them
margaret taylor greene nor lauren
beaubert actually do and even the people
from their districts are like dude this
[ __ ] lady is over in dc and she's
over here doing this and nothing doing
nothing for us she has abandoned us
they care more about the fame and
fortune of being a representative than
actually doing the job that they signed
up for and that's what that's that's the
truth of the matter for those two but
yeah they get so upset when aoc gets any
sort of limelight or any sort of like uh
coverage like this because they want it
because the only time now that they get
it is when it's on the negative they
said this crazy thing they said decisive
instead of divisive they said you know
gestapo police or gazpacho police
instead of
gestapo police they said you know
lieutenant uh corporal or lance corporal
it's
they're made fun of because they're not
real people they're just that's what
they are they're not they're aoc
they're moga bot
yeah aoc is real she is a representative
lauren bobert marjorie taylor green and
every other one of these [ __ ] manga
republicans they're not real people
right they are this shell of a human
filled up with hate obligatory
and in everything that is wrong with
america do you think if marjorie taylor
green would have picked a a flesh suit
for her for her uh manga robot that she
would have picked one with more than
three toes um here is the uh trends here
again queen elizabeth ii is turning at
number one because she has passed away
at the age of 96 uh buckingham palace
announces there's the other reason why i
i really and
she's dead is trending um god save the
king is trending but um betty white um
queen elizabeth here in the united
states um is trending because of this um
but the other thing because i think
royal family was also trending here
that's the one thing that kind of gave
it away yeah there it is number 24. um
it's trending at um
royal family philip is 22 her husband
passed away recently but here's the
thing
what gave this away to me
that she was gonna pass away
is they were announcing that harry and
megan were
like booking ass to
uh the uk to
give the you know be by her side which
it was a really good indication that she
was probably gonna pass away very soon
so um rest in power and there's a lot of
things
um
around the royal family trending today
so this is gonna take over the news
cycle gabe i have a feeling that we're
gonna hear about this for about a week
and a half two weeks even in this
country and i want people out there to
be very vigilant that not to i mean you
can you talk about
you know consume these stories about the
queen but don't let this
stand in the way of making sure that you
lean into your democracy because we are
not a monarchy here that is not what we
are that is not what we want to be we do
not want this to dominate the news cycle
where it drowns out the real news and
what these
[ __ ] fascists are trying to do
because we need to keep
keep our heads in the game here to save
our country and save our democracy
um because we have a lot going on not
just with the documents but now with
steve bannon being charged on six counts
of fraud money laundering and and
looking at five to 15 years right and
that's just in the state of new york
he's looking at up to a year in federal
prison for the charges that he's already
been convicted on on contempt of
congress that's not including what other
charges may come in these schemes around
the january 6 and what the grand jury
actually finds
in the dec in dc
uh for that criminal uh probe where
they're and and they've had more people
testify just in the last week um to that
grand jury so
it's moving fast we need to pay
attention to this you got to keep your
eye on the ball
because these [ __ ] like marco rubio and
dr oz uh jd vance uh blake masters
they're trying to walk away from trump a
bit because they know they're going to
jail even mitch mcconnell and that is
one clip i want to play here before we
leave because i want to play that clip
and you know what i want to end with
gabe i want to end with this steve
bannon this lady yelling at him again oh
my god he's so jesse
um but let me play the clip of yesterday
because this is important and a lot of
people call mitch mcconnell on coward
here which i mean he certainly is yeah
but um that's not i don't think that's
really what he's doing here is i mean he
is being a coward but yeah um i'll tell
you what i think he's doing here but
watch as a reporter ask him about the
classified documents
do you think it's appropriate the way
that the former president was storing
those top secret and classified
documents at his private estate at
mar-a-lago i just want to point out the
look on look at the look on these
people's faces do they seem excited yeah
about like guys stop talking about this
this is this is dominating the news for
and this is not good for us we've got
the midterms coming up right
because they they clearly see the
writing on the wall they're like [ __ ]
this is
we we need to shut the [ __ ] because now
they're like oh [ __ ] some of us need to
shut the [ __ ] up we need to stop talking
well my belief is gabe that mitch
mcconnell is no more excited than anyone
in washington that trump is gonna go to
jail here and the reason why and i think
mr mcconnell is okay with losing the
senate and possibly the house this round
just to show the world and to show his
party and to show the donors that trump
doesn't win elections trump does not win
you elections i will win you elections
give your money back to me give your
trust back to me give me the rnc back
not that [ __ ] buffoon i think that's
what he's saying and i think that's
what's happening but watch what is a
response to the question
you know i i don't really have any
comments on this this whole
investigation that's been
dominating the news for the last month i
think we're following it like all of you
are
classified
i think we're following it like all you
are because what he's saying is
he's [ __ ] he's go dudes going to jail
every day
every every few hours like every time
that his legal team is like hey we
challenged the doj and the doj is like
really you wanna you wanna do this again
all right fine and then something comes
out you know oh [ __ ] it was nuclear
secrets on foreign entities like what
the [ __ ] going on and they're like you
guys still wanna play this game you guys
still wanna challenge us and say this is
unfair and it's invisible documents and
they never existed and he was just
uh
collecting memories and [ __ ] you really
want to play this game okay fine let's
play it you know and every time they
regret it like this is the p this is the
group of people who are like you we want
it all transparent we want you to
release this stuff you know it's like
well you guys found you guys found out
what happened and you
maybe should stop [ __ ] around and
it's like nope we want to keep doing it
well here one last time let's watch how
we handle these maga republicans these
mongoloidites these [ __ ] traders
these fascists these america purse nazis
as this this beautiful woman in new york
um lays into steve bannon as he's
walking in the courthouse to surrender
to prosecutors on six felony charges
that could hold up to 15 years in state
prison let's watch
this irony on the very day the mayor of
this city has a delegation down on the
corner they're persecuting
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh she's after my heart you know what
you know you know who she reminds me of
who's that the two protesters who went
after uh
flake
uh uh jeff jeff flake in the elevator
after he said he was going to back
kavanaugh
that is who that woman reminds me of
right not all heroes wear capes guys
okay and a lot of these heroes are women
and these women are standing the [ __ ] up
for everyone else that's right that's
right and that is vibe i get from this
woman that's what i think we're going to
see in this midterm so everyone
as sad as it may be that queen elizabeth
has passed away we need to pay attention
to the news here in the united states we
need to lean into this we can do two
things at once you can chew gum and walk
at the same time so lean into your
democracy engage in it
engage in it and how you can do it is
you can follow us here on youtube just
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
we're here every single week noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and simulcast
to the facebook you also don't want to
miss the bone end of the week poll go
follow us on twitter at tony michael's
pod
today
new person in the running mate i think
so i think so so don't miss bonehead of
the week poll it'll be on here on
youtube and on twitter so go follow us
both places also download every single
episode
on apple spotify google your favorite
directory leave us a review and
subscribe there too don't forget to
subscribe to listen to us not just watch
us but here's the thing bone in the week
is tomorrow so be looking for that poll
because we'll do bone in the week in the
second hour tomorrow as you join us
and it will be what was that for
tomorrow oh okay great so what was that
and bone end of the week double surprise
you have to tune in tomorrow as you do
every single weekday noon easter at 11
central nine pacific for two full hours
same time same place tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking